artig der könig ist tecdoc tuesday
ja wenn man ihm freunde herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
episode tanktops news hier auf einem
kanal nicht würde sagen wir verlieren
gar nicht sagen zeit um starten direkt
drei mit dem besten tik tok der woche
die hp quality content
danach habe ich auch noch meine
instagram story gepostet wie mich meine
freundin beim schlafen dann fotografiert
mit der jagd
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dass laura tor
da verrate ich heiße annette und
bindende finca sitte du kannst mich ja
einmal anhören dann können wir uns beide
anhören
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir wieder in diesem ticket
user im moment an gelangen wo ich mir
dann einfach noch denke was bekomme ich
auf meiner homepage angezeigt
[Musik]
warum leite ich solche sachen immer
dadurch bekomme ich ja nur noch mehr
angezeigt
mai
warum ist die antwort klar ist
ja
nicht nominiert
missy may be made ich möchte mich mit
michael mich war
ich
das
gesagt nicht mehr was ich allerdings
will meine lieben freunde ist das ihr in
zwei wochen am 20 05 10 uhr luca - ok
vorbeischaut denn anstatt dieses sichert
sympathischer entspannt jeweilige
tragendes foto.de
[Musik]
ja
es ist lustig mit diesen ganzen filtern
aber ich weiß nicht ob ich da jetzt
irgend ein bisschen zu bedacht denke
oder zu vorsichtig oder zu sehr albern
lesen die ganze sache herangehe aber was
können wir denn da noch erwarten von
dieser ganzen technik wenn du schon
leuten ein lächeln so detailgetreu ins
gesicht zaubern kann
dieses leben ist wie diese blume obwohl
umsehen um kein anderer blumes
geschaffen hat hat sie nie aufgegeben
und jetzt steht sie und und sie irgend
jetzt
[Musik]
vergesst was ich gerade gesagt hab ja
immer wenn ich irgendwo gerutscht bin
sei es im freibad oder am schwimmbad
oder keine ahnung wo oder auch wenn
dollars oder so in dieser normalen
rutsch es muss ja nicht mal wirklich mit
wasser in verbindung gebracht seien aber
immer gab es dieses eine kind so man
selbst rutscht und er rutscht zu zehn
zentimeter hinter dir und du denkst sie
ganz allein mein genick bricht gleich
[Musik]
einmal kompakt camcorder ist es so
bietet
was schaue ich mir hier an sich selbst
reinigen des katzenklos
wo
[Applaus]
was für eine richtung rutschen wir hier
gerade ab apropos abrutschen allerdings
halte ich mir alles dabei da geht doch
die frau zu und sagt entschuldigen sie
richten sieht es auch
dann sagt sie was denn überhaupt nichts
nein es riecht hier so nach käse
er sagt die frau wieder ja wieso wir
nach käse und dann sagte er ja
irgendeinen grund muss es ja wohl haben
warum du mäuschen hier bist
warum
habe ich mich nach meinem studium nicht
für normalen job entschieden du sagst es
gibt so häufig diese momente greife eure
freundin komplett mit carolina
[Applaus]
warum bekomme ich so etwas auf meiner
for you page
zehn jahre lang hatte gross am 13
entschuldigung sind sie sich diese groß
sprecherin von tokios hause gerne
unterstellt mein gott sie sind es
wirklich
ich finde es so krass so die richtigen
gesichter von so stimmen zu sehen
ich dachte dafür dass alle schauspieler
einfach alle sprachen der welt sprechen
weil es zweifel meint verschiedene
sprachen aber das habe ich dann
irgendwann mit 19 jahren
[Musik]
b
und ich drücke an türen an den 10
[Musik]
was
hier dankeschön
ich habe hier wundervolles t shirt an
lukas ist da
warum habt ihr so ein großes problem mit
make-up ist doch ganz schön medial wenn
jetzt gut findet er vielleicht doch mal
ausreden
[Musik]
doch schon wieder unseren hochzeitstag
vergessen
nach durchaus ja-stimmen sorry charlie
du christ jetzt noch eine chance von mir
wenn morgen was in der einfahrt steht
das von null auf hundert innerhalb von
fünf sekunden ist dann lassen scherzt
duo sie
das ist so ein richtiges video was eine
über 40jährige schicken würden
zusammen noch mit zoom in ihren video
die dir alles gute zum geburtstag singen
[Musik]
das waren viel zu viele special effects
in einem video soll die post apple
[Musik]
das recht
als ein assistent begann an der stelle
möchte heutigen die politik setzt
allerdings auf beenden wenn freunde wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann lasse gerne
einen daumen hoch unter dem video folgt
mir auf den kopf heißt dort
laserdruckern wie bereits gesagt heute
auch schon lästig doch video hochgeladen
und schreibt mir euren tipp topp namen
hat und in die kommentare wenn ihr
eventuell in die nächste episode topused
reinkommen wollt wenn ihr euch für
dieses t shirt hier interessieren sollte
meine liebe leute seht ihr hier schon
meinen shop verlinkt am 20
um 15 uhr kommt dieses video dort
online.de online limitiert auf 2000
stück also seid schnell und abonniert
main kanal auf dem smiley und hier ist
die letzte episode vi top teams hätten
ich muss wissen
[Musik]